good day and welcome everyone i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
please allow me to welcome you to this edition
of our 2020 2021 foundations of biomedical data
science seminar series this lecture is supported
by uva's integrated translational health institute
of virginia the uva brain institute the college
of arts and sciences the school of data science
and through a grant from the national institutes
of general medical sciences it is my honor and my
privilege today to welcome our speaker dr david
kennedy from the university of massachusetts
dr kennedy is a professor of psychiatry at the
university of massachusetts medical school he is
the director of the division of neuroinformatics
at the child and adolescent neurodevelopmental
initiative called candy he has extensive
experience in the development of image analytic
techniques and was a co-founder of the center for
morphometric analysis at mass general hospital his
career has seen the advent of such technologies
as mr based morphometric analysis in 1989
the arrival of functional mri in 1991 and the
development of diffusion tensor pathway analysis
in 1998. he has a long-standing experience with
the development of neuroinformatics resources
and participation in the morphometry biomedical
informatics resource network or mburn dr kennedy
is the community liaison for the neuroimaging
informatics tools and resources clearinghouse
called mitric a fantastic resource for all
manner of software and executables that deal
with neuroimaging related informatics in addition
he is the founding editor of the journal of neural
informatics that debuted in 2003 and a pi of
repronym the center for reproducible neuroimaging
computation dr kennedy's lecture today is entitled
repronym towards reproducible neuroimaging
neuroscience as always we are stringing this
lecture live and for recording via youtube if
you are watching via youtube thank you so much
for joining us today also our specially selected
2020 2021 biomedical data science innovation
lab participants are encouraged to submit any
questions for dr kennedy by the chat feature
in their zoom sessions i will synthesize these
questions and ask them on your behalf during
the last 10 minutes or so of the lecture
and with that welcome david we are very
much looking forward to your lecture
thank you so much jack it's my pleasure to uh join
you uh in this you know exquisite seminar series
and uh as you were mentioning it's part of a
long-standing education and outreach effort
that uh again you've just been monumental in
in spearheading so i appreciate the invitation
um the introduction you provided uh while
nice uh means only two things one i'm old
uh but two uh i when i was young there were some
really cool things going on and so i was a very
fortunate uh person to be in the right place at
the right time during a development of all of
the sort of cool you know mri based neuroimaging
methodologies so that was an opportunity so um the
key driving uh topic i'd like to talk about today
is reproducibility and again it's motivated by
our nih nibib funded uh center called reprenim the
center for reproducible neural imaging computation
uh so reproducibility will be my main theme uh and
so i wanted to come up with you know some sort of
motivational types of things now reproducibility
is a problem in lots of different you know topics
we'll be specifically considering it in the
context of neuroimaging but uh all the concepts
and all the issues really you know are hand
disciplinary in terms of other fields and other
other you know approaches to brain and and science
in general that you know need to keep these kinds
of concepts you know uh you know in the front of
one's mind but uh by focusing um i often come back
to uh so so my work tends to be in uh psychiatric
applications principally child uh psychiatric
applications uh development and misdevelopment
and uh autism and other you know behavioral and
developmental uh disabilities so since i work sort
of on this psychiatric side of things uh one of my
go-to you know statements which really motivates a
lot of what i'll talk about and a lot of what the
center is really working on comes from a a paper
by tom insel and his colleagues tom insel at the
time was the head of the national institutes of
mental health uh and he was sort of bemoaning
you know the lack of progress you know in you know
sort of mental health in psychiatric uh you know
uh science you know generally and while i hate to
read a long quote i think i do want to read this
one to make sure that a couple points you know
come out so patients with mental disorders show
many biological abnormalities which distinguish
them from normal volunteers however few of these
have led to tests with clinical utility so again
that's lamenting the fact that you know today
you know the clinical tests we have in psychiatric
clinic are very similar to what they were 10 20 30
years ago before a vast investment in neuroimaging
a vast investment in genetics et cetera so again
we have very little new clinical utility
tests that have come out of this investment
several reasons contribute to this delay uh first
there's a lack of a biological gold standard
definition of psychiatric illnesses and again
this you know uh portrays you know the shift
that the national institutes of mental health
had back around this time from sort of diagnoses
to research domains of classification so again a
lot of the behaviors you know span diagnoses and
diagnoses tend to be spectrums and checklists and
things like that so not the best you know sort of
marker for what you know is going on you know
behaviorally when it's a checklist you know that
you're giving you that diagnosis so that really
you know launched you know this switch into
trying to find systems and circuits and behaviors
that go together not a diagnosis you know that
ends up being the end target a profusion you
know of statistically significant but minimally
differentiating biological findings you know
have emerged and to this you know we really
mean that you know over the past you know 25 30
years there's been tens of thousands of papers
and people have done you know tens of thousands of
studies have found you know things um uh but uh so
lots of things get found but these ultimately
are you know significant but not uh you know
informative in terms of you know outcomes and you
know uh treatments and and types of things to do
and this is you know confounded by the fact that
you know there are only approximate replications
of these findings uh and that's often done in ways
that neither confirm nor refute those findings
uh and so in the end we end up generating lots of
data lots of papers lots of grants lots of studies
but not lots of improvement in how and how the
clinician treats the patient and how the patient
you know the prognosis and the outcomes you know
for that patient and so that was you know kind of
you know damning uh you know assessment and really
is you know rather important you know motivator
how do we try to improve you know on this you
know kind of state of the art back in 2012 or so
uh so there's lots of reasons you know that
you know these you know concerns you know are
expressed uh and we'll talk about them and and
look at issues of them but you know certainly
you know we're using you know often low-powered
studies uh we diagnosis is not a great target
uh we don't really you know publish you know
proper and complete methods and results uh
and publication bias leads to you know kind of
a skewed literature and look at each of those uh
sort of ramifications as we
go through this presentation
so again while i'm using sort of a prototypical
analysis from the neural imaging domain hopefully
you in radio listening land can you warp
this into you know the appropriate stages
of your own you know type of work but you know
clearly we start with you know some sort of uh
data acquisition and uh you know activities and
experiments on subjects uh imaging you know things
like that generate a bunch of data imaging
data behavioral data apply you know analyses
uh and workflows in order to generate
some derived data and some statistical
results and we go off and publish those uh
and some of that data and all of that uh
literature you know become distributed you know in
pubmed and other sort of queryable you know places
so each of these stages you have different
implications about you know how we currently
do those and how those really can you know
evolve you know to trying to to do a better
job of you know improving our infrastructure for
doing reproducible uh neuroimaging neuroscience
um so coming back to one of those key
sub phrases of that insole you know quote you know
we have approximate approximate replications of
you know the findings we tend to find yeah in
a way that neither confirms nor refutes them
so again that is one of these you know driving
you know types of statements you know and
you know three points you know come to mind here
first that it's impossible to confirm or refute
something that you cannot first replicate so if i
see a paper and i want to confirm it or refute it
uh i'd better be able to start by being able to
replicate it in order to see then you know if you
know different data different uh approaches
you know uh find you know that same result
second you know we tend to not publish our
findings you know with the necessary details
in order to support replication so again the pdf
the traditional publication uh and word counts
and you know readability and sort
of the human aspects of things
really are not commensurate you know with
the highly digital highly you know complex
highly you know computational nature of the
science that we're doing so by by the definition
you know of you know words you know we're really
not you know providing all the necessary details
uh in our you know general way of disseminating
knowledge the the the publication so
the third point here is that when it comes
to examining either re-execution or the
generalizability of an observation or a claim
it turns out that every single decision that
we make every choice you know everything we do
matters in terms of that output you know result
so just uh walk through a couple examples
of this and again i think it you know
holds in many different contexts but just uh
to put some examples on to that last statement
exactly what operating system computer system
you're using you know can make a difference in
this case uh a simple paper that we talked
about you know later in the presentation
it takes the exact same software uh fsl version
5.09 uh the exact same data data runs it in a mac
operating system runs it in an ubuntu operating
system and documents you know that you know the
you know the same measures that are coming out
of that same software you know are different
as a function of of operating system now there's
ways to ameliorate this but again it's important
to know that you know even something as simple
as what your operating system is what your
version of software is what um the version of
the operating system is you can make you know
differences in you know what's the same data
and the same the same uh you know workflow
similarly and clearly not surprisingly you know
the data you know how much data you have uh
matters you know in important ways and the
little example i use of this is looking at the
uh sex effect of hippocampus volume uh in typical
subjects uh we could go back to the state of the
literature back in 2005 or so where you know
the nih funded you know a large study at the
time you know 325 pediatric you know population
across seven sites and this is the so-called nih
pediatric uh database you look at that data uh
large database uh look at the sex effect in the
hippocampus volume and you see you know sort of a
zero effect but a pretty large you know error bars
fast forward to you know 2011 where the ping the
pediatric imaging neurocognition and genetics
study you know gets published so that's you know
it's a 1200 study 1200 subjects from you know
eight more sites with a much more modern you know
imaging acquisition much more modern segmentation
technology and lo and behold uh we now begin
to see you know a sex effect in the hippocampus
volume emerge now this is not inconsistent with
that 2005 and that it falls completely within
you know the confidence limits of those original
studies but we've now tightened the error bars and
you know been able to you know refine the method
refine the measurements uh and get to a data size
you know that begins to let us you know observe
you know this type of finding then if you fast
forward further to 2015 more you know publicly
available data becomes available and then you can
you know see that you know that you know effect
you know has begun to sort of stabilize with
you know the new data that's becoming available
so again data size matters but not only size you
know sort of the era and quality of data matters
so just because again i'm one of the folks who you
know pushes very hard for lots and lots of data
sharing you know all along but again there is
you know data quality there is data age effects
and not all data is created equal but again to
assess that and understand that it's really better
to you know have that available and then to make
the choice and make those rational decisions
about how to use you know that information
as it's shared the um just they you know somewhat
trivial but informative you know exploration
you know of uh this you know number of subjects
type of issue in this case is a simulation
statistical simulation we ran using the ping data
again ping is a pediatric imaging neurocognition
and genetics you know study uh ran out of uh
san diego terry jernigan andersdale uh it had
12 000 subjects and so sort of our final
you know a little observation over here
is you know uh sort of the expectation of this
about 200 cubic millimeter sex uh based you know
volumetric difference you know in uh males
versus females in the volume of hippocampus
but you can you know easily do the bootstrapping
and sort of sub sampling exercises and if you
had uh you know studies of select you know
only you know 10 subjects from that uh 10
males 10 females and redo the analysis and
permute that you know thousands of times you
get this you know kind of distribution you know
of you know effect sizes that you would observe
uh pick you know 250 sub sub subjects you know
run that permutation this is the distribution of
you know effect sizes that you see so ultimately
you know all we're doing is you know actually you
know demonstrating you know the power you know
uh calculation in terms of an effect size which
is about 200 you know cubic millimeters and a
measure of a certain you know variance the free
surfer hippocampus volume measurement in you know
uh healthy you know children you know across the
you know 5 to 21 you know age range and we see
that for you know effect of 200 millimeters you
really need to have you know a 200 or 250 you
know subject you know size you know before you
begin to clearly you know clear that significance
you know of that effect and that distribution
so again not rocket science here but it reminds us
that again when when we're looking at small things
when we're looking at moderately large population
variants you know we really do need to get into
orders of magnitude larger studies than we
had been doing you know sort of in in the
old days and so again that n you know that you
know tends to be needed for even sort of a mod
moderate or moderate to small effect size you
know it's an important thing to keep in mind
and how that you know relates to the types
of studies and the subtleties of you know
cognition and uh uh mental health you know
that we're trying to disentangle relative
to larger effects such as sex and age and
socioeconomic status and genetic ancestry etc
so uh the next in line in the everything matters
uh rant is what tool you select you know matters
uh so while on the one hand we might be looking
at the volume of you know a cortical region the
left caudal anterior cingulate uh in this case
there's at least there's more but we're looking at
two different tools one called ants and one called
free surfer uh both of which make a measure of the
left anterior cingulate uh volume uh and in this
case we have two versions of free surfer version
5.1 and 5.3 and we have one version of this
ants software so the good news is you know free
surfer between versions has a very tight you know
correlation so they didn't do anything in version
5.3 to muck up you know the measurements
relative to what they were doing in 5.1
on the other hand the two free surfer measures
relative to the ants measures while statistically
significantly correlated uh are really
correlated at not an exceedingly you know high uh
you know fidelity so while statistically
correlated you know these really are not you know
exceedingly well and representative of this of
the same data now this is we're fortunate here
that this is you know 800 and some subjects so
we can you know see this you know correlation but
but again the the one measurement is not really
a you know great proxy you know for the other
measurement and so therefore a concept such as the
volume of the left caudal interior cingulate you
know is really rather different if you're looking
at it from the point of view of free server versus
you know ants so therefore the types of findings
and things you might see you know could be could
be different and so i'll use that uh as a
jumping off place to demonstrate you know
okay fine you know they correlate significantly
but it doesn't matter well the answer is yes and
i'll illustrate that but i'll also illustrate it
in the context of something called siegel's law
so siegel's law goes something like a man with a
watch knows what time it is so in this case uh if
my watch you know is free surfer i have one watch
my watch is freezer for 5.3 the time the analog of
time here is i'm measuring in this case you know
in the abide the autism brain image data exchange
i'm looking at the effect of the diagnosis of
autism or not uh based on the volume of a set
of you know 48 different cortical regions so my
one watch is free surfer i the time i'm measuring
is you know how different is the volume of this
region in the subject with autism versus subjects
without autism uh and i find you know a nice
set of you know regions you know that have a
diagnosis effect and a bunch of regions you know
that don't so this is just rank ordered on the
effect size and you know that's the time so to
speak the second part of siegel's law though
is but a person with two watches is never sure
because you know in general two watches are never
exactly the same and so if you have two watches
you don't know which one is right or either right
uh so having two watches you don't really know you
know at all exactly what time it is and again the
analog in this case uh is the effect that we
saw you know before that you know free suffer
and ants you know ants is our second watch uh
the time we're measuring is the you know effect
of you know the diagnosis you know of autism and
we see that our second watch gives us a rather
different you know view of time of you know where
the differences you know in the brain volumes are
in the subjects with autism versus um um you
know typical controls now again my point here
is not to argue about which is right or wrong my
argument here is to make sure that we're you know
acutely aware that different tools you know even
if they're measuring nominally the same thing you
know uh have different biases have different
you know assumptions uh and can give you know
different views and so the observation you
know of you know differences is really you
know predicated upon the exact tools exact
tool selection you know that goes on and
sometimes we forget that so that's part of the
point of making sure that we keep that in mind
uh and clearly again as well you know exactly
what this statistics one uses you know matters
so in this little simulation we go back to
looking at our fun uh hippocampus uh sex effect uh
we're looking at the ping data so it's about
1200 subjects uh we have a grand you know
volume as a function of sex is related to age site
socioeconomic socioeconomic status total brain
volume and genetic ancestry factor so those are
all the uh covariates you know that we could use
and all of these are known to have some effect
you know in the measurements of brain volumes
so we essentially permute you know create an
ensemble of these models you know one model
that only has age one model that only a site
one model that only has scs and a set of models
that have you know two of these age inside
age and scs age and total brain volume uh
et cetera so we create sort of all the
different permutations of these models
that could exist and ask what is the sex effect
given that you know ensemble of different models
and so here we're plotting the effect size you
know on the x-axis so this is an effect size
of you know 600 or so and this little grouping
here has an effect size about 200 you know or so
um and then the y-axis here is the r squared
sort of a goodness of fit you know representation
so what we see when we just plot all you know 128
of those models the permutations of you know this
set of factors is we see these two little clusters
this one cluster has a large effect uh and this
one cluster has a much smaller effect and the only
difference between these two clusters is when you
know brain volume is included as a covariate
now that makes complete sense you know sex is
related to brain volume itself so if we discount
you know the brain volume difference between sex
uh we get left with you know a you know radically
different you know representation so again this
big example you know covering for brain
volume makes you know a huge difference
in that it makes sense it also varies
with sex so you know that that's fine um
but more interestingly so each of these
circles is the uh effect size estimate
uh and the whiskers then are the 95 confidence
limit on that effect size estimate and so within
here you know again we're seeing a cluster
and many of these uh models are significant
you know i.e their whiskers you know don't touch
you know the zero effect size but not all of them
so some subset of these um models you know
if that was the model you happen to choose
are going to end up you know not being significant
whereas a different subset of those models will
end up you know being significant uh so again i'm
not here to debate exactly what the right model is
but only to use this as an illustration of
you know again exactly what model we're using
uh can affect what does or doesn't you know end
up being portrayed as significant and also some
of these models you know are much better at
predicting you know the overall variance of
the data compared to others so again when we took
out brain volume we you know doubled you know our
you know ability to you know accurately you know
model the data but we also dramatically reduced
you know the effect size of of sex on hippocampal
volume here but again that's closer to reality
since we didn't want the total brain volume you
know interfering with that observation of you know
the sex effect you know in the hippocampal volume
so again lots to worry about in terms of what the
right you know model is what the right approach
to modeling when there's lots of covariates and
lots of things that you know you know also have
significant effects on the observation of interest
so fine there's a bunch of sources of variants
that i've illustrated for you uh but you know
that's why we have a big literature that's why
we publish lots of things you know these sources
of variability will work themselves out in the
publish literature right well no uh and for a
couple reasons we tend not to publish negative
findings uh and that has to do with things like
publication bias and file drawer effect that we
could talk about further you know later if one
wanted to uh so that a given published false
positive may not see much contra indication to
it because you know people don't want to publish
you know the fact that you know that region didn't
you know show up they'll usually go and look for
something else that did show up and publish that
so when we see something when we do see something
that's different it usually gets wished away
with you know statements like oh you know our
population of you know autism subjects is a little
bit different or oh we use the different methods
so it's okay that you know we're getting you know
different answers and so now the literature
then you know gets you know a second answer
and a third answer and a fourth answer that are
all a little bit different and all implicating
you know sort of different regions and never
coming back and asking ourselves why are we
not seeing or are we not seeing some of the
common regions across these this different
set of publications and again so a trivial
or simple illustration of that is you know my
finding i look at these two regions region a and
region b region a is important and significant i
report that in literature yay you come along with
your paper uh you don't see anything in region a
but in this your case ah reason b is important
so you publish you know region b you know is
important so now both of these may be false
positives you know due to low power or or whatever
but our literature doesn't know that our
literature doesn't know our inconsistency
our literature just has you know region a is
important and region b is important you know in
this disorder and along we go you know merrily
next person who finds you know region b looks
through literature and says oh yes you know so
and so saw that i'm consistent with the literature
ignoring of course the fact that you know someone
else you know didn't see that so again these
ability to constructively or destructively
interfe you know sum up you know these
different findings is really just not happening
properly in the literature as as we reported
and that builds upon itself you know in a
literature uh and one of my favorite examples
you know of you know kind of a semi-pervasive
effect certainly in the volumetric literature
uh is documented in this um publication here
by anne lefevre and roberto torro uh in this
case they're looking at uh what was felt to be a
pretty stable finding that across you know lots of
publications you know in the autism literature
if you look at the corpus callosum volume
you find you know significant decrease in corpus
callosum volume as a function of autism so again
if you just read the literature you know you read
lots of articles you can find lots of articles you
know that support that idea fine you can then
go off and do a proper you know meta-analysis
of that literature and that's you know shown here
there's a 14 different publications uh and you do
the meta-analysis on this effect and you get
a significant you know effect you know of the
literature and you say yep that's what i expected
that's what i feel like when i read literature
all is well with the world the literature
is consistent on that despite you know some
saying the effect is really big and some
saying the effect doesn't exist in general
the literature suggests you know the effect
is about a 0.5 uh standardized mean difference
so uh what roberto torro's group did was you know
tried to conf you know confirm that so if that was
a true fine finding one would like to be able to
see that not just you know in the retrospective
published literature but in a prospective you know
set large you know data set of of data about you
know subject with autism and so in this case using
the abide the autism brain image data exchange
data they uh found you know 694 subjects uh in
the seven to forty you know year old age range
uh 328 our patients uh 304 you know our
our control i'm sorry 366 our controls
ran a particular software package free server
5.1 and looked at the corpus closum effect
well uh the types of things they observed were
things that you would expect you know there was
a significant side effect and that's been seen
and this came from about probably about 20 sites
so it's a large number of sites to generate this
data set but there was a significant side effect
there was as expected a significant age effect and
there was as expected a significant uh sex effect
but uh unfortunately the they did not confirm
you know a group effect a diagnosis effect
of this um you know corpus callosum volume
um and uh the diagnosis of autism so that's
you know upsetting and that you know something
that was so clear from the traditional published
literature that there should be an effect you
know couldn't be replicated in a prospective
uh mega analysis as opposed to the retrospective
meta analysis so it turns out there's
a good number of reasons and background
to this and i don't want to dwell too long
but part of the point is power the biggest of
those prior studies was 113 you know subjects uh
the biggest power to see an effect of you know 0.3
you know standardized uh effect size was only 36
so in general all of those publications that were
seeing this uh effect were woefully underpowered
you know to you know see that effect uh and if
there were an effect of that size there really
ought to be you know many many many more
you know publications or observations you
know that that did not see it so again this
is an example probably of you know this uh
publication bias of and uh uh reporting you know
bias whereas the mega analysis that was performed
you know had a 99 power to detect an effect
of of this you know 3.3 standard deviations um
and yet this is the publication that did not you
know see this so the scarcity of negative results
is a problem and the woefully under power
in retrospect the willful underpoweredness
of the literature that went into that original
meta analysis you know is is you know problematic
so ultimately what you know this kind of refers
to is not that nothing is going on in the corpus
closum but the model of that same sort of simply
diagnosis you know relates to you know corpus
callosum volume is really too limited to model
and you know these studies were underpowered
to look at sort of the covariate sort of
the whole system of what's going on here
is that you know diagnosis you know is related to
brain volume diagnosis is related to iq iq is you
know also related to the brain volume and so all
of these things you know are co-varying together
uh and you know so yes there is an effect in
corpus callosum but if you control properly for
ice q and control properly for brain volume
uh that effect is not necessarily a direct
effect of diagnosis and corpus callosum so again
by getting to properly you know sized studies to
be able to more you know efficiently you know
disentangle you know the types of covariates
that are going on one can change you know the view
of you know sort of what the causality or what the
relationship you know in that uh model will be
how are we doing one time okay so fine lots of
things are a problem i always get yelled at
for being a rather pessimistic person and uh
most of my um uh research associates you know get
very annoyed with me for being so so negative so
let's try to turn a little bit more positive here
so steps to recovery doing truly reproducibility
reproducible neuroimaging research is hard there
are just so many things that we've seen that you
have to do you know to get it right so that's
where sort of reapernym has been trying to focus
you know a lot of our efforts in terms of you know
establishing sort of a comprehensive set of tools
and practices that are designed to advance the
reproducibility of each of these critical stages
of the neuroimaging research process so again i've
sort of alluded to this but i you know want to
say this even more explicitly is you
know reproduce what so there's at least
two domains of places where we're concerned about
reproducibility i may want to reproduce in the
sense of re-execution of a specific result so for
a specific paper given the same data given the
same approach can i re-execute that observation
so in this data set with this tool can i confirm
that the hippocampus is 203 millimeters larger in
the boys and the girls great that's interesting
and useful not very scientifically you know
exciting but uh sort of an important you know
founding foundation point the slightly more
interesting scientific question is reproduce
in the sense of generalizing of the claim that
when i use different but similar data and a
different but similar approach can i generalize
can i reproduce the same you know claim that
you know came from my original observation so
the general claim you know might be something
like hippocampa are larger in boys and girls uh
and to generalize that you know i need you know
additional data to confirm you know the claim that
may have come from my first observation for that
to generalize in the literature or across you know
other observations you know use additional data
use additional tools that look at uh volume and
if all of those you know collaborate then we can
begin to generalize and reproduce the claim that
inhibited by indeed are larger in boys than girls
but if there was something about you know the
measurement of fifa camp i or something about
how i claim uh how i what i meant you know by
boys versus girls or what the age limits are
or things like that you know might matter and so
therefore one may have to be careful in how they
distinguish the groups by which you know this
observation this claim you know holds over and
so again so all sorts of things that just have to
be a bit more careful than we tend to tend to be
so fine a different version of the
same thing is this you know original
data the original paper you write you know has
some data has some analysis has some result
we argue that what we're missing the first thing
we're missing is this concept of re-executability
and i'm guilty of this especially because i'm so
old and i've been doing so many studies for so
long that i probably cannot get to the same data
from a study i did and get to that same analysis
and verify that i can get the exact same result
from a paper five years ten years twenty years ago
so we really you know i and i think semi exemplary
of the of the literature you know are not you know
really engaging in science and in the way that you
know we can at least establish you know the sort
of core re-executability of my original finding
but having that re-executability in place is
really the necessary you know foundation point for
systematically and you know sort of scientifically
exploring the generalization of my claim so can
we muck around with similar analyses on that same
data and get a similar result does the tool matter
uh can i you know use that exact same you know
analysis and use similar data you know you know my
kids with autism compared to your kids with autism
if the finding really is related to autism it
shouldn't matter if it's my set of kids or your
set of kids if it's really about you know volume
it shouldn't matter if i'm using this tool or that
tool if these are valid valid tools so ultimately
we want to get to the generalization statement
that in similar data and similar analyses should
yield that similar result but we'd like to be able
to do that in a systematic way and not you know as
we kind of right now we have my paper and we have
your paper which is on similar data and similar
analyses but we can't rationally understand the
differences when i don't replicate and we don't
know and uh which you know often you know happens
and this is because we don't really characterize
our data and our analysis and our results very
well in our current literature and this idea of
similar has lots of wiggle room and how one can
use that into their own purposes again if you're
trying to write some if you had you know two
functional you know mri experiments and each had
a foci of activation you know close but not quite
overlapping well if you wanted to tout the novelty
of your uh approach you could say ah my approach
and their approach get in completely different
spots because they don't overlap great if you
had a reason that you wanted to you know say the
similarity of these results well you know those
two spots yeah they're close they're part of the
same system i'll say there and you know there's
you know anatomic variability so again at the
behest of the writer one can often you know take
results and decide if it suits them better
to call them similar or dissimilar to their
to their purposes and again this happens just
because we can't get to the exact answers and the
exact methods you know to both of those types of
observations and really use those in a systematic
fashion so the steps to recovery really uh i'll
try to illustrate you know by example here and
then work backwards to how we might you know get
there a traditional publication uh publishes some
traditional you know correlation analyses
we see a pdf you know plot you know we see
a bunch of observations we see a you know fit
somewhere in the text you know they tell us
all the details of how the data was analyzed
and how the statistic was done and what the
magnitude of the effect was and you know blah
blah blah lovely you read it and you're happy
the repronum variant of that really wants to
shift uh you know do a sort of paradigm shift
under how we do that same publication uh in sort
of the reproducible re-executable fashion so in
a repronum version of this you know same plot each
point knows in some canonical sense you know all
sorts of information about where that point came
from its provenance who was the subject you know
that that point is representative of what was the
demographics what were the clinical variables et
cetera what mri scan was used you know to generate
you know that you know observation what was the
scanner what was the acquisition date retails and
where is that scan living you know at the moment
on my hard drive out in some public repository uh
what workflow was used you know that gen took you
know that mri scan and turned it into this you
know volume of a corpus closed some measurement
and this is a volume of a corpus callosum
measurement well where does that fit into the
constellations of measures you know what is a
volume what is the corpus callosum what part
of the you know brain does that belong to how
does it relate to other other parts of the brain
so all of those are features of every point that
we should be able to generate and if we just keep
the provenance and keep the annotations about
that point as we generate it they each know point
you know can then you know sort of recreate itself
that point knows what workflow what generated it
that workflow you know can exist in a container
or somewhere that can be you know re-executed
so given that point it can be regenerated
by anyone who had the container and
the ability to execute that given that you know
you can get to that data and you can get to that
specification that could be you know anyone could
re-execute that it also supports then the concept
of generalizability if i take different data i can
do the exact same analysis if i you know take that
same data and you know open up that container i
can change the tool i can change the parameters
on that and so be able to you know explore the
generalization of that point because all of its
history all of its execution all of its generation
you know can be captured you know in a formal way
uh and in that sense the point is fair uh
in that in some way you know that point can
be housed locally or publicly in a way that's
findable accessible interoperable and reusable
and hopefully that will resonate a bit with
uh marianne martone's presentation from from
a while back uh so fine if we can generate
points in that way that would be great uh
the statistic has the same issue the statistic
you know has a version has a you know
an execution has a container in which it
runs so given that this pilot data uh this
statistic can be rerun given a different pile
of data the exact same statistic can be run
given you know the same or different pilot
data one can has the framework to then version
control and track and understand differences
that one might make in that analysis approach
great um so
that i just set up sort of a wish that you know
gee yeah what would i have to do to make all the
provenance and all the metadata for each of my
observations and each of the you know statistics
and interpretations of that observation you know
so what do i have to do to actually accomplish you
know that uh and that's hard so one of the things
reaper nym has also tried to do is to stratify
the process into individual components each
of which individually are not as hard as the
whole you know thing and each can be adopted
individually and each contribute to the overall
reproducibility of the research effort so the
reproductive platform is a sort of a virtual path
through lots of different components that we try
to improve you know sort of piece by piece one's
ability to do these things just because it'd be
hard to do everything at once and start a whole
new study and do it this way but if we can get
you to do simple things uh that are a little bit
better than what you did in your prior paper and
then through your sequence of you know learning
and and doing things a little bit better you know
we all can sort of improve the background and the
underpinnings you know of the published you
know literature that we that we generate
so the stages of research that we you know
dwell upon you know sort of five you know steps
that we'll refer to there's studies design
data collection data processing statistical
analysis and the publication the principles
that we try to apply to each of these stages
include you know sort of proper
planning proper version control
use of standards uh annotation and archival
and so in each of these different stages
we at reapernym and you know the community as a
whole have a number of different tools and and
resources that are you know available to assist
in you know sort of promoting you know sort of
the reproducible uh execution of each of these
uh different stages so in terms of study design
you know you might in the planning stage you
might really encourage you know pre-registration
uh version control really cuts across everything
as you do your study design that may evolve well
we better understand why and when it evolves so
you know what it is you know you end up doing
and there's annotation you know that can be done
with the neural imaging data modeling similarly in
collection we want version control taken care of
so there's tools like data lab we want standards
such as repro in and bids you know to be used
we want annotation to really describe what it is
we're acquiring and we want to do that at the time
of acquisition uh because it's easier to do when
you're designing and uh collecting the data than
it is to do five or ten years later when you go to
publish it and can't remember what the sam three
variable you know really means uh and there's
tools for archival and we don't need to go into
details of this there's lots of tools and lots
of resources you know that can be applied to sort
of each of these different uh areas and again we
could talk further about those tools specifically
if they are important or interesting to to anyone
so again a second version of uh seeing the same
thing uh you know has to do with so these five
steps that we we mentioned and you know a set of
tools you know that really support you know doing
them and again the point here is that you don't
have to do everything correct uh most reproducibly
to start with pick something oh i want to do
my uh data analysis you know using datalab
okay well do that and that's better off than you
were before oh i want to use version control for
my scripts okay use git and do that and you
know each of these singular things you know
are steps to you know overall improvement of
the of the overall system so the last concept
is fine we talked conceptually about you know
wanting re-executability at the paper level
we talked about a bunch of tools
that are available you know for
for doing elements you know of that so where
does this bring us where do we end up uh we end
up in this concept of the repro pub which uh is
this re-executable publication and of the future
is slightly i mean you can do it today uh but
again a lot of our efforts are trying to make
it you know more routine you know to do these
sort of completely re-executable publications
now what do we have to do to do a new version of a
publication that is re-executable well yes we need
humans to read it and understand it and like you
know the study you did so we need our words but
we need to include additional digital machine
readable supplementary you know information
we need to explicitly indicate what data went
into the analysis we need to explicitly define
you know the exact details of the workflow
specification we need to ex explicitly and
completely define the execution environment
you know that supported the running of that
analysis and we have to provide that complete set
of results not just the story you'd tell about it
because that makes a good story and that's
important but the complete set of results
is what's necessary in order to one verify you
know that it's re-executable and two to support
the negative findings and the anti-findings
and the uh mixing and matching uh findings
you know across the complete set as opposed to
the garden path story that uh you know you tell
about the results that make sense you know to
you so you know we need sort of a completely
executable research publication that requires
the complete description the provenance you know
of the data workflow execution environment
and results so we've done a couple examples
of this the first one we refer to as simple
one which was really you know just you know
you know 20 subjects from the nitric that
are imaging informatics tools and resources
clearinghouse publicly available data a
very simple fsl you know volume workflow
run in a very simple uh ubuntu you know container
built with neurodoctor uh and so the data you know
is a data set which is you know identifiable and
you know machine readable and machine accessible
the workflow and the results you know are in
a github repo that's been uh archived into a
specific you know doi you know through zenodo
and the execution environment is a particular
container that lives at you know docker hub so
anyone you know could read this paper get to the
data get to the workflow get the environment and
verify that they could generate the same results
and this was done in a very simple situation so
you could you know if you wanted to to do that
and to verify that you got the the right answer
so to some extent one doesn't really want to do
that but one wants to know that they can you know
do that and wants to be able to represent you know
publications you know in that way but
this is a silly paper didn't really do
anything scientifically it just demonstrated the
concepts of these of these pieces and the their
connectivity in a traditional publication that can
still accompany with these accompanying documents
achieve this this objective so more complex
example that i'll end on here is uh you know
trying to do that same thing but actually do it
in a biologically interesting thing so we searched
the literature for iq and typically developing
children discovered uh three different papers that
you know did some tasks did some observations of
iq and structural variables uh so we given uh we
need to discover you know our own data that's
appropriate for that we need to prepare that
data in a semantically appropriate way we need to
select a workflow that makes the measurements that
we need we need to execute that workflow we need
to make sure our results are represented in that
semantic representation and then we need to
query that and do the statistics you know that
verify or replicate you know the findings
that we you know developed from the literature
so again in this case we can do that with
pre-registration of hypotheses that came from
literature we have a structural workflow that you
know is using neurodoctor to containerize a free
surfer an fsl and an ants uh you know software and
that container you know and workflow is available
the data sets come from abide one an adhd200
publicly available and the statistical analysis
and results you know are published you know as a
as a jupiter notebook so again we've accomplished
the same things of yes we can write lovely words
about this but each of those elements in addition
to the human readable words are associated with
machine re-executable you know uh elements and
so this is just one of the hypotheses that total
brain volume will positively correlate with iq
in both sexes across the complete age range here's
the data uh we found you know uh a significant
you know effect here and the original report had
a significant effect here of a very similar sort
of magnitude so cool we re-executed that the old
report you know was not re-executable this one
is and so anyone could take our version of that
yes it's nice that we re cr recreated the prior
expectation but ours you know can now live and you
know be added to or manipulated as as one sees fit
so overall in these three papers there were nine
hypotheses you know that were generated uh and you
know six of those you know we replicated in the
abide in adhd 200 data but three of the findings
that were you know you know from the literature
didn't replicate and so again so one can now
yes that's sad that this didn't replicate and
we can't really again they use different data
than we did and we used a slightly different tool
than they did so we know this difference is but
at least from our version of this you know one
can now expand and explore that uh in ways that
you couldn't you know if you failed to replicate
you know their observation you know originally
so final slide uh so uh for some reason this
uh dawned on me that you know i should end
with the wrath of of god or the wrath of the nih
and you know use this fear factor um uh ending
uh reproducibility just do it or else you know
you won't get funding we know there are new data
policies coming from the nih you know that are
going into effect which are much more stringent
in terms of data management and data sharing even
now progress reports and uh competing renewals and
things like that can be held up or you know not
awarded if you're not doing your data sharing
data acquisition you know appropriately you won't
get published if you don't work on reproducibility
many journals are now beginning to you know
enhance their data sharing and software sharing
policies uh and if you can't get funding and
you can't get published you won't get tenure
that's semi a joke since most people don't really
get tenure these days anyway but that's okay
but most importantly john oliver will laugh
at you there's a whole lovely segment on
on the this week with john oliver you know
lamenting how badly you know many scientific
studies and how badly the the news media deals
with uh scientific studies that are done in
irreducible fashions um and then so ultimately you
know adopt reproducibility by design that's much
easier than doing reproducibility at the end and
i thank lots of folks from the reapernym team uh
and the many institutions and the many uh groups
you know that work with us and we are available
uh via websites emails twitters monthly webinar
training materials youtube channel etc and
thank you i'm sorry a little bit longer than i
probably should david thank you very much for that
uh fantastic uh overview of the importance of
reproducibility what it means for for science
and and all the the effort that you guys have put
into not only sharing your ideas but your code
and your uh tools for so doing i think it's
great um one couple of questions so um i was
impressed by looking at some of the meta analytics
summaries that you provided and you had mentioned
publication bias as one of the sources and
i've published in this area a little bit myself
especially neuroimaging and so have a little um
you know my own thoughts about this but i wanted
to pick your brain a little bit about the sources
of publication bias in neuro imaging for example
um what are some of the sources of that
and also would we do better by not just
reporting small p values and saying oh look
something was statistically significant but
doing a better job of reporting effect sizes
power estimates and stressing what is there beyond
just a small p value does that make sense yes
uh that makes sense i think there's a lot of
impetus to get away from maybe not abolish not
defund you know p-values but uh really you know
downplay p-values and make sure that effect sizes
are reported make sure that power is reported
because again to some extent you know so much
of what we and again the two issues with power
is there's retrospective power you calculate
from your observation which you know if you're
have found a you know spurious false positive
you're going to miscalculate the power anyway uh
but uh again looking at the difference between
you know prospective power and retrospective power
and what the what that is and we'll find
that an awful lot of the findings we do have
are rather significantly underpowered doesn't mean
they're wrong but it means you know their positive
predictive value the likelihood of seeing
that again in a new study you know is not
as good as you know an observation that came in
a better powered you know study so again i think
yeah there's a lot of movement towards you know
effect sizes and you know observed power and you
know really grappling with and just embracing
or understanding and working with the fact that
you know things are underpowered and you know
need this replication so while i sometimes sound
negative about you know small underpowered studies
not everyone can do 10 000 you know 10 year olds
and follow them for the next 10 years to look
at everything you want to do i can't be against
you know small underpowered studies what i am
against is small underpowered studies that are
done in sort of a private you know closed you
know space that no one that don't have a chance
of you know being contributed into the bigger
literature to become part of a properly powered
prospective study so that i think is the problem
is you know closed low-powered uh studies not the
presence of low-power studies i think that's
a fact you know then i just won't fund things
that are big enough and to report power to report
effect size and publication bias there's so much
requirement you know to publish and even if one
isn't you know actively p hacking you know there's
just lots of you know i don't say laziness but
lots of things that people do which are not quite
as you know copacetic in the long term uh in part
just because again myself included i didn't really
know any better and were quite anxious you know
to find something you had to publish out of this
and i think the pre-registration therefore
becomes an important part of that
to help uh avoid some of the publication bias to
help promote the publishing of negative findings
and again the challenge with negative findings
is yet to be properly powered you know again
negative findings don't magically overcome the
power issue you can be equally underpowered
for a negative finding as well so again all
these things just need to be more transparent
more published uh so that they can be put together
and built upon and understood with respect to each
other more efficiently fantastic i i liked how
you hear funnels slide there about what are some
of the incentives for reproducible science and
you when there's the carrot and the stick kind
of classification if i will um one of the things
i'm curious about though is in thinking about how
data scientists um and people who are involved
in computational um the inner the enterprise of
the brain as a computational science
um what can their role being uh be in
you know helping to support
reproducible brain science
oop you're muted my friend yeah someone has to do
that in every presentation right yeah um that's
right and the answer i gave that for a second
was was spot on so i'll just uh yeah um the uh
not gonna it takes a village in the sense that you
know we as authors just need to be aware of this
we as you know grant writers you know need to be
aware of this we as reviewers of grants reviewers
and publications need to um step up you know
our review uh criteria we as you know editors or
or um you know leaders of you know publication you
know platforms you know really need to embrace the
rigor you know side of this again it's not that
you can't publish things that are underpowered etc
etc but we just need to be doing this you know in
a framework that you know is you know constructive
you know as opposed to you know sort of siloed
into individual publications and i'm not sure
if i answered the question you asked but that
was well it just it seems that there's so much
opportunity for data scientists who are very
interested in developing tools that help promote
a science of reproducibility within the science
of the brain um a huge opportunity for that and so
the whether it's the development of ontologies
or computational tools or frameworks for how
publications gets uh reported uh in the you know
in 2021 i think there's enormous opportunity i i
think you'd uh be one of the first people to agree
yes absolutely and just because we have a handful
of tools i meant to say and perhaps did say that
someone said i don't care how you get your version
controlling or how you get your annotation or
how we have some tools for that would be nice if
you used ours as long as you get your data into
standards that others can use it as long as you
report the provenance of what you've done so
that others can re-execute it uh i don't care how
and who's tool and the opportunity to lower the
barrier to doing that is is great and again it's a
lot of an efficiency thing people you know the end
user you know needs to be able to do these things
relatively efficiently we can't slow sign a
publication down to a crawl or else people
get upset so we need to be efficient and deliver
them the ability to do these things going forward
david kennedy thank you so much for
sharing your thoughts on reproducible
science that is a fantastic amount of work i
really appreciate you sharing that with us today
um everyone who joined us thank you so much
everybody enjoy your weekend and we'll look
forward to seeing you next week thanks again
david thank you jack and thanks to you out
there in listening land and i hope to see you on
the reproducible side of things excellent bye-bye